ET là
Le
En dehors de la logique Ah écoute ce que je vais dire
Mais écoutez ce que j'en ai tiré aujourd'hui
là avec
digresser pour aider parce que vous pouvez là et
ici le
roi mais pas difficile Santos Reis
de rien Casa de Pedra Redonda TPB
dumm dumm dumm de la rodilla peut y aller
alors vas y
donne ça
pierre plus fine là où la mer combat le
vagues là Gilmar combat le soja de sonde
la pandilla aujourd'hui laia laia laia
laia laia laia
rien à la maison là-bas yeux d'argent
en argent véritable peixinho.de
et puis là les gars aujourd'hui là vous pouvez
laia laia laia laia
en attendant la réponse ici la bouche
bien ici de ta bouche est venu tu peux là
aujourd'hui lâche lâche prise
Il vous captera des sons